et has your quick look at the cover
stars hitting newsstands this month I
mean it's awesome kendall Jenner graces
the front of v magazine's January issue
she goes pantless in a sexy ensemble
revealing a giant temporary snake tattoo
on her thigh kendall is one of six cover
models inked up by a tattoo artist for
the mags Forever Yours edition yeah
we're eating next up Hilary Duff opens
up about co-parenting and dating in the
februari issue of Cosmopolitan inside
the glossy the younger star gushes about
her amazing ex husband mike comrie
admitting quote i wouldn't choose anyone
else to co-parent with we are really
good friends and care a lot about each
other Plus Duff says she's not quote
desperate to find a mate you know I go
out on dates and it's nice but I'm not a
super focused on that right now we just
don't know a way to work at NASA son I
had no idea t heard quite a few women
working in the space program and ladies
of hidden figures fiercely posed for
essence check out taraji p henson
Octavia Spencer and Janelle Monae
looking regal in chi gong fumbles for
the max temporary issue henson gets
candid about the significance of this
role for her growing up people told her
math and science are for boys your
computer at nest and then women handle
that sort yes
you